my creepy little fish arms you are so
quick come here daddy oh my sweet child
your chest yeah if you look down your
face like goes into your chest and your
knees are already in your chest
oh there's a there's a strange object
here which is Oh God oh this is very
it's very inappropriate you put down the
stranger over object can I pick it up
what daddy wait Oh daddy we need any
ribs rematch hey I found bleach no no no
take anyone don't drink the bleach whoa
come on Oh party ha ha ha ha do that
again I want to fly I don't know how I
did it
are you and inside it I got a fork I got
a four can get stopped at me let go
overboard na whoa laughs no let go gave
me the fork come here daddy
okay stab you with a fork oh god there's
an electrical cabinet there I got a
pretty no Tim it no no your trash put me
in the trash oh I wasn't going to trash
hey you are going to trash going I want
to go it twice you're going to try here
you go said yeah that's really nice okay
I can close it
sameen trash I'm so strapped huh this
game is clearly flawless ten out of ten
ten out of ten
IGN best IGN out of ten IMDB Oscar
Rotten Tomatoes flawless game
Karlis game Wallace Balki half love it
oh yeah I'm in it can I interest you in
a bucket perhaps